our other top story here at 11 a heated
night at the ccsd board meeting is
parents and teachers argued over masked
mandates thanks for joining us i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis many
in attendance are not in favor of
wearing a mask even though the cdc at
this time says mass are really a
critical step in preventing the spread
of covet 19. sasha loftis at tonight's
meeting she joins us live with what was
heard there at the meeting sasha
denise and brian this meeting was really
out of control the moment it started
frustrations boiled over and the whole
thing became a shouting match still
those against mass mandates in schools
urged ccsd board members to reconsider
tensions explode as the school year's
first ccsd board of trustees meeting
rages out of control so that is
incredibly disrespectful
you're being disrespectful to me dozens
attended to participate in public
comment
many making their stance against masks
known you have to take the vaccine and
wear a mask it's ridiculous others like
district teacher sarah comroe say face
coverings which are mandated for nevada
students from kindergarten through 12th
grade are a welcome protection against
covid19 i have over 200 students so you
think i'd have at least one
not one
every single one is happy to wear their
mask she also voiced her frustrations
over constant disruptions
as trustees paused to deal with those
refusing to mask up and others leaving
the building in handcuffs
they are forcing us to have these
situations where meetings where business
needs to get done
are interrupted so while not much was
accomplished in the planned agenda those
here took the opportunity to demand
action we urge that to defy the
directive and threaten to take matters
into their own hands my body my choice
right
again it was very difficult for the
board to cover really any items on the
agenda thoroughly tonight because of all
the disruptions there was also a
credible threat made from one audience
member to another and a police report
was filed here reporting live tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now